good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp 2009
object class ketter
special containment procedures samples
of scp-2009-2
are to be kept in refrigerated bsl for
compliance storage
at biosite 98. should an instance of
scp-2009-1 be required for testing or
interview purposes a single d-class
personnel is to be exposed to 3 grams
of scp-2009-2 following exposure
the affected individual is to be
contained in a bsl4
compliant containment cell for a period
of no less than 9 days
after which point it is to be treated as
a new instance of scp-2009-1
infection of d-class personnel with
scp-2092
is to take place only with the approval
of at least two on-site
level four personnel for the duration of
testing
the instance of scp-2009-1 is to be held
in a bsl4 compliant containment cell
kept at 10 degrees celsius humidity in
the cell of scp-2091
is to be kept at zero percent foundation
personnel are to wear level a hazmat
suits
when interacting with scp-2009-1 and
are to undergo full decontamination
following interaction
following completion of testing or
interaction the instance of scp-2091
is to be destroyed and its remains
incinerated
medical facilities news media and law
enforcement are to be monitored to
detect
uncontained instances of scp-2000
after confirmation and assessment of
scale mobile task force row 8
mushroom hunters is to be dispatched to
effect containment
description scp-2091 is the designation
for all instances of an anomalous male
humanoid
capable of asexual reproduction by means
of spores
instances of scp-2091 are genetically
identical
and prior to mutation display no unusual
physiology
instances of scp-2091 are fully sapient
and are capable of socializing normally
up until the point of production of
instances of scp-2009-2
instances of scp-2009-1 identify
themselves as thomas wang
no instance exhibits knowledge of its
anomalous properties
all instances also have a shared
baseline of memories
including childhood and early adulthood
taking place in the community
of pollensby california if exposed to
temperatures of more than 20 degrees
celsius
and humidity in excess of 40 for a
period in excess of five days
scp-2091 will seek out a darkened area
with preference given to tall buildings
and places adjacent
to high foot traffic areas the body of
scp-2091 will begin to distend and split
into thin
chitin-based hairs these hairs will be
used by scp-2091 to anchor itself to
nearby walls
objects and if possible draw limited
sustenance from them
scp-2091 will cease sapient activity
converting all of its energy to the
production of scp-2009-2
scp-2009-1 will continue the production
and release of scp-2009-2
until it eventually dies of exhaustion
scp-2009-2 is a microscopic spore
created by scp-2091 capable of infecting
human beings
during a typical period of production
scp-2091 is capable of producing
55 kilograms of scp-2092
instances of scp-2092 are airborne
and infect humans through the
respiratory system with three to four
days of exposure
individuals infected with scp-2009-2
will begin to experience symptoms of
nausea lethargy and
photosensitivity additionally
individuals will shun social contact
isolating themselves from others within
five to eight days the physiology of
affected individuals
will begin to change to match that of
scp-2009-1
the process can cause varying levels of
discomfort
proportional to the physiological
similarities between the individual
and scp-2091 affected individuals are
aware of the changes
and frequently exhibit extreme
psychological distress
during the process within eight to nine
days of exposure the physiology of the
subject will exactly match
that of scp-2009-1 as will its baseline
psychological state
dna and memories newly created instances
of scp-2091
exhibit no knowledge of their lives
prior to transformation
scp-2009 was discovered when reports of
a widespread infection
by a previously unknown disease in the
town
missouri were made to the center for
disease control on
1998 foundation agents embedded in the
initial response team reported extreme
psychological changes
brought on by exposure to scp-2009-2
in 46 of the town's residents the town
was immediately quarantined
with infected individuals being taken
into foundation custody
the cdc teams and the remainder of the
town's residents were isolated
until the nature of scp-2009 became
apparent
the town was destroyed and incinerated
under the cover story of freak wildfire
on 1998. the cdc teams and
uninfected residents were dosed with
class e amnestics
and released from foundation custody the
next day all but three of the newly
created instances of scp-2009-1
were destroyed and incinerated with the
rest used for purposes of testing and
the creation of instances of scp-2009-2
for purposes of study during the
destruction of the desiccated remains of
an instance of scp-2091
were found in the bell tower of first
methodist church
it is suspected that this instance was
the original vector
for scp-2009-1 although it is unknown
whether it was the original instance of
scp-2009-1
this is interview log 2009-7 m
13th of november 1999
playing log now interviewed
d 998 120 w abbreviated to d 998 by dr
amador
for conversational purposes an african
female
four days after exposure to scp-2009-2
interview took place in a darkened bsl4
compliant containment cell
hello d998 how are you feeling today
if you do not feel like cooperating d998
i can't turn the lights up
over i feel awful i feel like vomiting
and light hats everything nice what did
you give me
i'm sorry to hear that please describe
your earliest memory
if you would anyway if i answer
can you go away once you answer this
interview will be complete
yes okay i was five
for six my mother had to work late
and when she got in she just fell into
the chair the little room and fell
asleep
i thought she had died what did your
mother look like
what do you mean she looked the same she
normally does
short and a dark yellow skin
ranting thank you for it
that can't be right what did you thank
you that will be all
and this is interview long 2009 7n
15th of november 1999
playing log now interview notes
d998 120 w had been informed that
any feelings of bodily dysphoria were a
result of vaccination against
malign restricula
d998 how are you today i'm not
good really oh and why is that there's
all of this
noise like i'm not me i'm
people and who are you
thomas wang i mean i know i'm thomas
wang but i keep remembering this stuff
like my dad dying when i was a kid or
getting a
c in art class but they're it's not me
i'm from poland's be not columbus my dad
is alive
i mean do you want to hear the weirdest
part
please i remember stuff like girl stuff
like having you know what
never mind i didn't just say that
i think i understand like you know i'm
comfortable with myself and everything
it's just
is this gonna be a thing no no
such a reaction to the regimen we put
you on is totally within parameters
you should be over it within a day or so
okay
thanks doc closing statement
on 1999 the transformation of d998 120w
into an instance of scp-2091 was
completed
following completion of testing the
instance was incinerated
end log
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening
if indeed you still are and you're all
dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran the morrigan
retalias karim el ashmuy
big onion bean scio dio demnatus
revenant brian sanchez
sister hintern patrick bailey
matthew gilmore eric corbin
kawaii fire keeper longinus
carcass ethakwa king maring
james saba nj vojak
and oblong doucheboy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash thevogen
thank you
you